one of the most common questions people
ask me is how do I come up with a good
idea for a side project maybe something
that looks good in my portfolio
something that makes money or both it's
not very easy to build something that
stands out so today I present you a
seven somewhat random and unusual app
ideas and you're free to use these ideas
to make money off them as long as you
subscribe and hit the like button now
before we get into the ideas there's a
few things you need to know ideas are
cheap execution is everything when you
come up with a great idea it's probably
not unique there's going to be hundreds
if not thousands of other developers out
there with the same idea what's not
cheap is the execution that takes
real-time intelligence and money now
with that in mind I'm also going to show
you the architectural patterns and
technologies you can use to execute
these ideas and we'll also talk about
how to monetize them my first idea falls
into the category of data aggregation
where you start with some data or
information and add value to it in the
United States there's a very obvious
schism and the way the news is reported
at any given moment you can pull up CNN
in one tab and Fox News on the other and
you'll often find headlines that seem to
come from two different universes this
app idea will archive the content from
both CNN and Fox News every 15 minutes
allowing a user to historically scroll
through the news and see how it's
reported on these two different sites so
it's kind of similar to the Wayback
Machine web archiving service but
obviously a much more specific use case
and now the question becomes how do we
execute this idea I would set up a
scheduled pub/sub cloud function with
firebase that would allow us to run a
background job every 15 minutes with no
js' inside that function I would use
puppeteer which is a headless chromium
browser to scrape the content from both
Fox and CNN I would take a screenshot
and then also scrape the text so we can
search through it this data would then
be saved in a storage bucket and at that
point all you have to do is create a
client-side app to view the content and
that could be as simple as a calendar
that allows your user to navigate to any
day in history easy enough but how do
you monetize something like this you
could display advertisements although I
think copyright ownership might be an
issue here I think this idea should fall
under fair use but check with your
lawyer first if you're more concerned
about making money you might offer web
archiving as a service to companies that
want to view a history of their web
deployments you could bill your
customers with a monthly subscription
fee and my stripe course can help you do
that let's move on to idea number two
which falls under the broad category of
building something data-driven
understanding how to work with and
visualize data is extremely valuable
but unless you're a massive tech company
acquiring high quality data can be
difficult one of the best free sources
is Kaggle there's all kinds of open
source datasets and every year they have
a big competition for March Madness
basketball for this idea we use
historical data to build a predictive
model for next year's tournament the
data of course can be visualized and
would make an awesome portfolio project
you could do all of this directly in
kaggle or you could add your data to a
data warehouse like bigquery once you
have the data there you can visualize it
and create a Python Jupiter notebook in
the cloud in the case of bigquery you
can run machine learning models directly
on this data without any ml knowledge
yourself and this can all be done in a
Jupiter notebook and made available on
the web you could monetize it by
offering a premium report for people who
play fantasy sports or for Vegas now
let's move on to idea number three which
falls into the very popular category of
photo editing this idea is especially
geared towards developers building
native mobile apps the idea is an app
that can take an image and apply
artistic photo filters based on ASCII
characters I was actually looking for an
app like this recently and they're out
there but I just wasn't satisfied with
the results so there might be an
opportunity to build a better app here
it could work just like any other photo
filter app that converts the pixels into
ASCII characters or maybe you could even
use emojis here here's one way you might
build it I would start with a flutter
app there are multiple plugins you can
use to capture images from an iOS or
Android device once you capture an image
you can think of it as a matrix of
values that range from 0 to 255 then you
just need a simple algorithm that
converts a pixel value to an ASCII
character or emoji you can then tweak
that algorithm to make multiple filters
you can then monetize it by selling
premium filters as micro transactions or
in-app purchases and that brings us to
idea number four which falls under the
game category a web-based game I really
like is geoguessr it takes you to a
street view somewhere in the world and
you have to guess where you are by
finding that point on the map the closer
you are the more points you get the only
problem is that after you play a few
games you'll have to upgrade to a
membership you should definitely support
independent game developers but as an
alternative you might just reverse
engineer the entire game one way you
might tweak it is to run the games on a
timer so everybody can play against each
other in real time so my idea here is to
create an MMO version of geoguessr that
might sound a little more difficult than
some of my previous ideas it's actually
easier than you might think
the first step is to build a web
application that integrates that Google
Maps draw
script SDK from there you can use
firebase and firestore to create a
real-time instance of a game in your
database that everybody can listen to
you could then use a scheduled cloud
function or back-end server to flip a
game to active and then calculate all
the scores in the background if you do
build this app you'll definitely want to
monetize it because Google Maps and
Street View is very expensive to use at
a large scale you can start by
monetizing with ads but that likely
won't be enough so you'll probably want
to add a membership or something along
those lines
in fact if you're interested in building
a real-time game and david east and i
will be doing exactly that on his
channel next week using spelt and
firebase so make sure to set up a
notification on his channel another
great way to come up with app ideas is
to look at what various api is out there
offer one of my favorites is Twilio
because it lets you do all kinds of
creative things with voice text and fax
the cool thing about their SMS API is
that you can send text messages to your
users or have your app serve as a
middleman so users can exchange messages
without actually exchanging real numbers
so here's my idea an app that allows you
to anonymously text someone based on
their geographic proximity imagine
you're at a large event and you want to
text somebody without actually meeting
or knowing who that person is in real
life the app would allow you to send and
receive messages anonymously with other
users who are within a 1 mile radius to
implement something like this you could
start with firebase phone authentication
that would give you a phone number to
work with then whenever two users start
a conversation you provision your own
Twilio number that maps those two
numbers together now in your client-side
application like flutter for example you
would be keeping track of the user's
geographic location when the users are
no longer within a mile radius of each
other you destroy the mapping so they
can no longer exchange messages an app
like this could be monetized by limiting
the number of messages that a user can
send they might get the first 10
messages for free then after that have
to buy credits to send additional
messages now let's segue into idea
number six which falls into a broad
category of specialized calculators
people love to fill out surveys and get
useful information return back to them
examples include things like net worth
calculators or inia grams where you fill
out a survey and get some analysis about
your personality and other apps like
social blade will retrieve data from a
third party API then create an analysis
about a social media account so here's
my idea now more than ever companies
need to save money you could develop a
survey that takes in information about
the cloud services that
company is currently using you could
then compare those inputs across
multiple clouds like AWS Asher and GCP
this could help a company implement a
multi cloud strategy that offers the
lowest possible pricing implementing
something like this mostly just comes
down to the front end you'd likely want
to start with a single page application
framework like angular react review and
then build a highly polished set of form
inputs to collect the users data once
you have that data you can make a
request to the cloud billing API to
fetch the latest pricing now this idea
might be somewhat difficult to monetize
directly but it could be a great way to
generate leads for consulting contracts
and now we're ready for ID number seven
the world is currently a crazy place and
there's a ton of people working from
home I'm sure the current crisis will
end in the not so distant future however
I don't think the trend of people
working from home is going anywhere
it'd be almost impossible for an
individual developer to build an app
that competes with something like slack
or discord
however these platforms allow you the
developer to extend their software by
building your own app they're pretty
easy to build and there's a great
opportunity to help out businesses that
are scrambling to get everybody to work
from home so here's my idea it's a video
conferencing app that allows you to hold
a synchronous meetings a person can
start a meeting over video and then
other users can respond with video as
well when the meeting is over all the
video clips get combined together so
other users can watch it later so it's
kind of like the Marco Polo app but more
business-oriented and directly
integrated into slack if I were to build
an app like this today I'd start by
looking into the AWS amplify video
plug-in it seems to provide a very easy
path for getting real-time video
integrated into a web or mobile app and
that's likely to be a very valuable
thing for a lot of developers going
forward I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if you end up building
one of these apps please let me know so
we can feature it on the channel and if
you want to learn how to build an app
from scratch consider becoming a pro
member at fire ship IO thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]